he told me that you'd be the one to
follow and me [ __ ] did it changes now
I'm back in the beginning you can do
anything but it's not like that anymore
you need some hose this is how we treat
each other this is what happens when you
don't just end it before it began it's
on us to make it work no that don't feel
right
[Music]
it's been a while since we had one of
these talks it wasn't that long ago we
were fighting just to stay alive but
it's not like that we build it we're
growing still ready to deal with this
world on its own turn
we're all gonna pitch in and make sure
that sanctuary has what it needs so
y'all can get back on your feet bless
your garage
no matter what happens
it's human nature to come together
that's a real pretty picture you paint
that ring when do I get to see don't you
ever get tired the bad thing like you're
stilling with your horns do you know
when were five the Savior's you told me
that soon you'd be the one to follow in
me but you didn't because I wasn't
someone to follow their changes now do
you think you got all this on lock you
need to start talking about making some
rules and agreement between all the
communities like this is how we treat
each other this is what happens when we
don't
Darrell stop that small group we had
back in the beginning
he could do anything that was right
just don't feel right
John Ross
figure out how to make it work
we don't know if they're ever gonna
forgive each other Rick
if they can even move on
I just wanted to pull that trigger
and before it begins
[Applause]
when it finally goes to [ __ ]
and there we'll make sure you come back
and you tell me all about that date
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's about all of us together keep doing
that they'll see we're all on the same
side
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we don't same salary will you tell me
who were you before before all this I
was a music teacher where two tables at
a truck stop she says she was a
journalist but she's just being modest
and who are you now incoming here we go
you